>> Regarding health care, I think not only
should be [INAUDIBLE] but
also the pharmaceutical company have a duty
to provide medicine where
it's needed in country that can't afford to
buy those medicine.
Because, any where they don't consider a market,
and there is need.
For instance HIV treatment in places like
Nepal or whatever where I
live to follow treatment will be 2, 3 months
of waiting every month.
So it's impossible.
So that's why there's a duty from the manufacture
companies, also, to
provide at a price that can be afford.
So that's a human duty and that's would be
also extraordinary to
express the sense of global responsibility.